[Musique]
dans les cours d'école il existe des
jeux c'est comme ça un sensible aux
effets de mode
la marelle bien sûr en fait partie mais
le classique des classiques c'est sans
conteste le jeu de billes des fois dit
que ce sont des vrais partis mais en
fait ce sont des fausses et le tu prends
la bia l'autriche alors la bille objet
de disputes mais aussi de culte de
drague et de troc la ville reine d'un
monde où chacun s'invente ses propres
règles le but c'est quand même le gain
c'est gagné et puis bon bah alors yahia
chez alon j'avais dix essais j'avais dit
que ça marchait pas donc puis bon il
s'amuse y soit un petit peu un petit peu
de cinéma à chaque rentrée 100 millions
de vies envahissent le marché et moi et
moi et moi pourrait dire jean pierre
rôle leader français de la bille
installé tout près de rennes cet homme a
révolutionné le monde bien lisse delaby
et ce grâce à un procédé d'impression
unique en france qui permet d'apposer
sur la bi tous types de logo en
particulier publicitaires les
entreprises retrouvent en quelque sorte
leur jeunesse
lorsqu'on leur parle de be ils se
rappellent leurs souvenirs d'enfance et
le concept plaît immédiatement les cours
d'école envahi par des marques de
lessive de chaussettes ou de chocolat un
concept potion magique qui devrait faire
exploser le marché de la vie dans les
années à venir c'est bien connu les
adultes sont de grands enfants qui ont
passé l'âge de la récré mais qui n'ont
pas perdu le sens des affaires
[Musique]